Cosmic Ghost Rider is going to destroy
an infinity stone in this comic it's
crazy so for those of you guys who don't
know who he is Cosmic Ghost Rider is one
of the most OP characters in Marvel
Comics just so overpowered but he's also
got one of the best Origins ever the
origin for his character isn't Thanos
wins you'll find it below the like
button in the description but to sum it
up in like 10 seconds in effect Thanos
shows up on Earth at some point in time
and basically kills everybody The
Punisher strikes a deal with Mephisto to
kill Thanos but mephisto's deals always
come with a trick so while Punisher was
given the power to kill Thanos by
becoming the Ghost Rider he couldn't
leave earth eventually Galactus shows up
to consume Earth he turns Ghost Rider
into his Herald and then Ghost Rider
becomes Cosmic Ghost Rider done and done
now the thing about this is that what
ends up happening in this comic which is
more of a backup feature than the main
story itself is he basically wakes up to
his wife Maria who's essentially dead
most of you guys know that from the oars
and story of The Punisher but Maria's
corpse just starts like crawling towards
him in this really grotesque way and
then as he's trying to get away suddenly
these old platoon mates from when he was
fighting in the Vietnam War Boston and
just start like shooting the place up
going after Frank Castle now at that
point he turns into the Ghost Rider
which is one of the big differences
between Cosmic Ghost Rider and the
traditional Ghost Rider traditionally
back in the old days in Marvel Johnny
Blaze Danny Ketch those guys couldn't
really control when they turned into the
Ghost Rider they were able to eventually
but Frank Castle it's like going Super
Saiyan right he just does it on a whim
and so once this happens he takes these
guys out and then immediately Galactus
shows up and when galatus grabs him and
snatches him out of what's basically his
home he's just in like this infinite
expanse of space surrounded by the
corpses of everyone he's killed or who
has died as a result of his actions
collateral damage that kind of thing
because one thing to understand is that
Frank Castle under normal circumstances
in Marvel tries to minimize collateral
damage to a degree right I mean if
killing 100 criminals requires the
deaths of five innocent people I mean
he'll do it right you know it's just
kind of the way it goes but with Cosmic
Ghost Rider he's not that way collateral
damage doesn't really matter it's just
the Target and that's effectively it and
so a lot of the people that you see here
were just kind of caught in the
crossfire but Galactus literally tells
him like you are guilty right you are a
person who's committed heinous crimes
you deserve to die for your actions now
here's the kicker he says you look a
little bit different gallon is that a
new haircut that's a test right when he
says that it's a test the response of
Galactus is as my Herald you help
sustain my insatiable hunger devouring
the worlds of many of those who came
before you today judging Mortals for
their crimes making a deal with Mephisto
fighting beside the Mad Titan literally
Cosmic Ghost Rider joined Thanos at one
point by destroying time out of a
misguided sense of morality you finally
Stand Accused for your crimes Ghost
Rider and he just kind of starts
cracking jokes right like well I mean
I'm not really standing am I I'm more
like being held in place but the reason
why he's so Cavalier here the reason why
he doesn't really care about what's
going on is because he realized the
moment and he referred to Galactus as
gallon it wasn't actually Galactus the
reason why is because Galactus before he
became what he is was known as gout but
precious few people in the universe are
allowed to call him that the Silver
Surfer sometimes Reed Richards pretty
much all the time and maybe one other
person and like that's it right Cosmic
entities of course because they're more
his equal but like that's it the fact
that Cosmic Ghost Rider was able to
refer to him as gallon without being
screamed at tells him immediately that's
not Galactus so he literally uses this
power kind of escapes captivity for a
second and then is met by his kids and
is supposed to be tormented by this idea
that his kids are there asking like why
did you let us die but the fact that he
knows none of this is real allows him to
just eradicate him on the spot right you
have like the corpse of Thanos who shows
up and starts attacking him he takes out
Thanos right like each one of these guys
is obliterated with the greatest of ease
it takes virtually no effort but all the
while he's basically saying I want to
know who the man is that's pulling the
strings I want to know the person behind
all of this who's trying to manipulate
me and trying to get me to go crazy
potentially even finish all my living
myself whoever this person is I want to
know who they are and so casting aside
all the Illusions using the power of the
Ghost Rider he ultimately ends up
figuring out it's just a dude it's just
like an alien out there and like that's
it right and this guy is just kind of
like you're the reason they're all gone
right my family my entire planet they're
all because of you you led Galactus to
my world and Galactus consumed it and
everyone died but here's the kicker to
this right it's very easy to dismiss
this it's just kind of like Ghost Rider
doing a thing if you're familiar with
Marvel this is massive because what
Marvel just did is they elevated the
power of cosmic Ghost Rider to one of
the most powerful beings in all of
existence because this guy has in his
possession the reality Stone this alien
dude is just using the reality Stone
what this means is that Cosmic Ghost
Rider was able to overpower the illusion
of the reality stuff the reality Stone
in Marvel Comics is not like it is in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe where a
person who is capable enough can
override its influence and see reality
for what it really is no when a person
has the reality Stone their power is
absolute they can make reality whatever
they want it to be only beings of the
highest level of power Cosmic entities
of the highest order are able to at
least compete with the reality Stone let
alone override the only person that
we've ever seen in the history of Marvel
Comics that was able to override the
power of an infinity stone was the
Living Tribunal and that was during the
old Adam Warlock and the infinity watch
comics in the aftermath of Infinity
Gauntlet when Adam Warlock went nuts
with the gauntlet and the Living
Tribunal shut its power down so that
never happens right the fact that he was
able to do that is insane not only that
where this guy is just like crushed and
devastated the response of cosmic Ghost
Rider is like look I'm sorry but what
you're doing here will not bring them
back and Magic always has a cost you
using this reality Stone will inevitably
either drive you insane or you'll become
corrupted by its power right he even
says you will only Lose Yourself and so
he takes the reality Stone and crushes
it in his hand the cosmic Ghost Rider
crushes a reality Stone this is
Uncharted level of power if we've never
really seen characters who have been
able to do this he then like opens a
portal and leaves so Cosmic Ghost Rider
just went from what was basically a
Herald of Galactus with pretty cool
levels of power to effectively a god
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end really cool story I
thought I'd share it with you thank you
all for watching and I will catch you
all later peace